Hãy bình gọi hành hình khổ chăm mấy mì sấu,
sật lượng truyền bay qua cảnh hàng khong của tế phụ Quốc,
được dự báo tăng khoảng năm 2019 to với tết ất tị hành hình khổ chăm mấy mì lâm.
Chúng mình mỗi ngày,
xân bay sẽ khai thác khoảng 7.5 truyền bay,
những ngày cao điểm có thể đặt từ tạm người đến tạm với tư chuyến.
Tổng lượng hành khách ước tính vượt về trong hành mấy mình in lợt,
trong đó cả khách Quốc nội và Quốc tế điều tạm mạnh.
Đáng chú ý, ngày 1 tháng 2 khi nhận tạm mi sảo chuyến bay đến phụ Quốc,
ngôn năm 2019 tế và 7.6 truyền nội điện,
với hơn 8.6 trăm năm 2019,
mất cao kì lục kể từ khi xân bay đi vào hành động năm 2019.
Chức áp lực tăng chường,
xân bay đã chú động bộ xung nhân sự,
chẳng thiết bị giả só thạm tân,
và quý hợp trời trẻ với các hành hành không,
nhằm hạnh trế uống tắt tại khu vực trách in,
sợ chíu an ninh và băng truyền hành liếng.
Huyện nâng gấp, mở dần cạnh hành không,
hướng tới công sốt 20 triệu khách 1 năm trước thêm 8.6 trăm 2.7,
được kì vọng sẽ thạo động lực mạnh mẽ cho dù liệt và kinh tế xa hội phụ Quốc trong thế giản tới.